porque nos llevó a pensar que debíamos hablar al ser humano
y no al soldado.
Teníamos que distanciarnos de la palabra
desde el gobierno al ejército, de ejército a ejército,
y teníamos que hablar sobre valores universales,
y sobre humanidad.
Y fue entonces cuando sucedió lo del árbol de Navidad.
Esta imagen que tengo aquí,
es la planificación de los árboles de Navidad,
y el hombre que ven aquí con las tres estrellas,
es el capitán Juan Manuel Valdez.
El capitán Valdez fue el primer oficial de alto rango
en darnos los helicópteros y el apoyo que necesitábamos
para poner estos árboles de Navidad,
y dijo en esa reunión algo que nunca olvidaré.
Dijo: "Quiero hacer esto porque ser generoso me hace más fuerte,
hace que mis hombres se sientan más fuertes".
Y me pongo muy emotivo cuando me acuerdo de él
porque murió más tarde en combate y realmente lo echo de menos,
y quería que todos lo vieran, porque era muy, muy importante.
Él nos dio todo el apoyo para colocar los primeros árboles de Navidad.
Lo que sucedió después es que los guerrilleros que salieron
durante la operación del árbol de Navidad y todo eso
dijeron: "Eso es muy bueno, los árboles de Navidad son estupendos,
pero ¿saben qué?, realmente ya no caminamos.
Utilizamos los ríos".
Los ríos son las autopistas de la selva,
y eso es algo que hemos aprendido,
y la mayoría del reclutamiento se hace en y alrededor de los pueblos rivereños.
Así que fuimos a estos pueblos rivereños,
y le pedimos a la gente,
y probablemente algunos eran conocidos directos de la guerrilla.
Les preguntamos: "¿Pueden enviar un mensaje a la guerrilla?"
Recogimos más de 6 000 mensajes.
Algunos eran notas que decían, salgan.
Algunos eran juguetes. Algunos eran dulces.
Incluso algunos se quitaron sus joyas, sus pequeñas cruces y objetos religiosos,
y las pusieron en estas bolas flotantes que enviamos por los ríos
para que las pudieran recoger por la noche.
Enviamos miles de estas por los ríos,
y luego las recogidos si no los recibían.
Pero muchos llegaron a ellos.
Esto generó, en promedio, una desmovilización cada seis horas,